my best friends and greatest resources
in this business
our friends from my time at Carnegie
Mellon and so I encourage them to learn
if they don't already know how to make
allies how to be there how to serve
other people in friendship because those
are the very people Billy Porter was at
school with me and he I have a card on
my dressing room table with his advice
to me about how to do this Tony run I
feel like one of the first Tony's I ever
won was the one he won he wanted for me
but that's okay
and also Leslie was not in school at the
same time as me but the spirit of that
fraternal sorority love that we have
extends really beyond who I was in
school with so I would encourage them to
start use each other lean on each other
support each other be loyal to each
other make friends bond with each other
you know I have had lifelong friendships
from that Rory O'Malley's in the show
everything right now is was in my class
at Carnegie that and then on a more
serious note I would say don't just work
on the things that you're good at you
know that's gonna be the temptation
because you're gonna want to you're
gonna want to impress people but in your
private voice lessons and your dance
classes work on that left side work on
that if you're if you have a problem
with vulnerability work on that stuff
because you want to come out and you
want to be abroad when these broad as
you can do that's that